[Music]
what you get if you combine a World War
- Thompson submachine gun a cut-down
Remington a 70 the shield of a spas-12
shotgun and a slightly twisted
imagination the answer is one of the
most iconic weapons in science-fiction
history I am of course talking about the
m41 a pulse rifle first seen in the 1986
sci-fi blockbuster aliens the pulse
rifle has undeniably struck a chord of
pop-culture and its sleek futuristic
design has influenced everything from
the armory of Halo to the prototype
weaponry of the US military so what
exactly is it that makes this big bug
hunting weapon so iconic within the
fiction of the aliens universe and as
stated in the United States clone
Marines technical manual the m41 a pulse
rifle came from a period of great change
within the USMC based on the whelen
corpse storm rifle the m41 a was
established as a replacement for the
outdated colonial marine Harrington
assault rifle and entered into service
in the year 21 71 eight years before the
setting of aliens
rifle fires 10 millimeter explosive tip
caseless ammunition at a rate of 900
rounds per minute an effective range of
500 meters as well as having the ability
to fire in the vacuum of space this
explosive weapon also came equipped with
the armored u1 pump-action grenade
launcher that can fire a suite of
explosive ordnance dependent on the
situation at hand but in the real world
the concept of the pulse rifle was the
brainchild of director James Cameron who
after taking over the franchise from
Ridley Scott wants to put his own mark
on the series he visioned his sequel as
a sort of Vietnam War movie but in space
and as a result sought to make an iconic
weapon to fit that type of film alien
sees the cocky technologically superior
colonial Marines thrust into a hostile
situation that they're not expecting to
face a scenario not unlike the
experience of the US military during
their campaign through Vietnam
underlying the the cool action space war
movie was this quite serious idea and
the idea of the overconfidence
of the armed man getting overcome by
this
unknown quantity and you see this in the
kit so the the pulse rifle if you really
squint you will see the silhouette of
the ar-15 the xm177 which for Special
Forces was fitted with a grenade
launcher underneath much like the put
one on the pulse rifle and a sliding
stock much like the one on the pulse
rifle and it's got the short barrel for
jungle fighting or fighting in built-up
areas just like the pulse rifle and even
the carrying handle of the m16 you kind
of see how that's evolved into the
shroud of the pulse rifle as well with
cameron's Vietnam War inspired concept
as the driving force for the design of
the m4 one a the production team
enlisted Simon Atherton of the UK prop
armor a bap TN Co to design and build
the prop and his original plan was to
use a heckler & koch mp5 as the rifles
base while the submachine gun had made
an impact on screen in movies like Rambo
First Blood Part 2 as well as being a
popular choice for military and police
forces in over 40 countries it didn't
match up to the vision Cameron had in
mind
so the mp5 the H&K mp5 that Jim Cameron
wanted because it looked a bit sort of
streamlined or futuristic and they could
jump off from there didn't have enough
muzzle flash we've got to have muzzle
flash in films and in games so they
hunted out something bigger bigger
caliber Cameron and his production team
tested a whole range of weapons in the
process of finding the perfect prop and
the special features of aliens you can
even see archived footage of tests being
done with an mp5 as well as an Uzi
before they finally landed on the
Thompson m1a1 submachine gun a weapon
seen in both the hands of world war ii
american infantry as well as the
gangsters of the 1930s
while they landed on the tommy gun to
make up the bulk of the weapon the pulse
rifle was far from complete the next
task will be to craft the lower parts
the weapon and introduce a pump-action
grenade launcher which you can see in
the movie used most effectively against
the alien Queen herself the bulk of this
was built from a cut-down Remington 870
shotgun with the heat shield and action
handle of a Franchi spas-12 added on to
better suit the hefty design they were
aiming for each weapon had a custom-made
an iminium shell that was crafted by a
British company that specialized in
creating lightweight racing car bodies
in an effort to keep the weight down the
weapons were then painted round but they
actually looked military olive-drab due
to the lighting onset the futuristic yet
functional looking she'll fit the brief
to a tee Vietnam War meets deep space
but while it looked the part there was
still one major issue with a prop the
weight with the prop maker Simon
Atherton even calling it extreme the
Thompson is a heavy weapon even before
you start adding all the other pieces to
it so a number of lightweight stunt guns
were used in shots that required no
firing and while a few were constructed
that were only able to fire blanks only
one had a functioning grenade launcher
attachment that particular model was
aptly dubbed the hero gun as it's the
one that Ripley uses throughout much of
the film another iconic and recognizable
element of the weapon is the almost
electronic buzzing growl it makes when
it fires James Cameron and his team told
for two days on the sound effect alone
creating the iconic growl of the gun as
it fires the end result was a sound that
embodied raw sci-fi intensity while also
evoke in the intended artistic direction
of a space born Vietnam War so what
became of this iconic rifle is believed
that only six of the functional props
still exist some would be rebuilt and
painted black to equip the
weyland-yutani operatives in alien 3
where the pulse rifle would appear once
again and one of these was purchased by
the rule armories in the UK as part of
their collecting cultures project where
it sits to this day preserved as one of
the most impactful props in science
fiction movie history beyond its
cinematic origins the popularity of the
Alien franchise meant that the pulse
rifle would go on to find its own life
in the world of video games the weapon
first appeared in 1993 when sega
developed its own light gun arcade
cabinet that provided an alternate
plotline to alien 3 the game was
inventive li title to alien 3 the gun
and cast the player as a Marine
returning to fury 161 the same planet
from aliens to rescue any survivors from
that movie's ill-fated mission
[Music]
fast forward to 1996 however and it was
much easier to wield a pulse rifle from
the comfort of your own home when the
alien trilogy released on PlayStation
Sega Saturn and ms-dos the game was
loosely based on a combination of the
plot from the first three alien movies
and was heavily reminiscent of doom with
much of the gameplay bearing a striking
resemblance to that of its shareware
shooter perhaps the most famous use of
the pulse rifle in videogames though is
in Sega and rebellions first-person
shooter trilogy alien vs. predator which
let players experience the game as the
Xenomorphs themselves a predator or a
pulse rifle wielding Kelowna marine the
original 1999 game in particular did a
great job of bringing a spirit of the
pulse rifle into the virtual world with
rebellion taking particular care with
the details
there was an on-screen ammo counter just
like the one from the rifle itself the
grenade launcher was satisfyingly
explosive and most importantly rebellion
absolutely nailed the iconic sound
effect
sadly the last major game that allowed
players to pick up the pulse rifle
themselves was alien colonial marines
which suffered from a myriad of bugs and
technical issues at launch released in
2013 and developed by Gearbox many Alien
franchise fans were excited to get back
into the boots of a colonial marine
while the game managed to create a
convincingly authentic atmosphere it was
let down by pretty much everything else
the story the AI the graphics the list
goes on and as for the pulse rifle
itself
the weapon was unwieldy and unsatisfying
to use but despite the negative
reception the game would go on to sell
more than 1 million copies
it's hoping that future games in the
alien series will once again give us a
pulse rifle that matches up that in 1986
silver screen spectacle the pulse rifle
has undeniably struck a chord within pop
culture aliens came out in a decade pack
with blockbuster movies that each had
their own iconic Armory Blade Runner The
Terminator
the Empire Strikes Back and Escape from
New York all came out in the 80s so the
aliens production team really had to
create something that would make their
firearm stand out from the crowd for me
it's the look of the pulse rifle
it was quite prescient actually in terms
of firearms design or at least
reflective of it at the time it looks
like a real military weapon designed for
a purpose and that's relatively rare in
film and TV and even rarer in games that
something looks like it has a practical
purpose it's region impacts following
its iconic 80s debut was such that it
was widely emerged often from the most
unlikely of sources in the episode the
lastest gun in the West The Simpsons
showcased the weapon as part of a foiled
bank robbery with snake and his goons
using pulse rifles to fend off the
police while in command & Conquer
tiberian sun GDI soldiers can be seen
using an approximation of the weapon in
cutscenes Saints Row 4 even had a skin
for its burst rifle called the impulse
rifle which had an extreme resemblance
to the original but with an added four
grip and the pop culture of Marge's go
on and on the pulse rifle has been
featured in everything from Archer and
South Park to Steven Spielberg's 2018
blockbuster ready player one
an m41 a posh wife would also go on to
influence firearm design in a slew of
video games in the virtual world we can
see the influence of the pulse rifle in
the blocky handles thicker lower barrels
and digital ammo counters of many of the
weapons used in modern video games you
only have to look as far as the human
arms and the Halo series to see where
the inspiration comes from or toward the
STA 52 from Killzone or The Vindicator
and mattock variants of Mass Effect
rifles to see the weapon design that
also taps into the same aesthetic that
made the pulse rifles so iconic even in
the real world in the 1990s the US Army
was looking for their new weapon and
surprisingly the universe of aliens was
brought up as an inspiration the
objective individual combat weapons
program was founded to create the next
generation in personal small-arms for
the US military the XM 2900 icw featured
advanced targeting as well as its own
micro grenade launcher similar to that
of the m41 a pulse rifle and before you
believe the similarities to be pure
coincidence during the development phase
the team actually stated they wanted the
weapon to look more sci-fi and
reportedly even use the Starship
Troopers morita rifle as well as the m4
1a as sources of inspiration I think the
other thing about the pulse rifle is the
sort of combination weapon thing any
weapon especially a gun that has an
alter an alt mode and alt fire is just
intrinsically more fun to watch or to
play it's got the the counter counting
down on the side which is just total
nonsense for a practical point of view
and that's purely cinematic that's only
there for the viewer to enjoy and of
course we've seen that paralleled in in
videogames umpteen times and there's
something about the the silhouette of it
as well that that shroud the shape of
that shroud is just it almost like
lightning in a bottle for a sci-fi
weapon for me decades later we are still
seeing elements of the m41 a pulse rifle
in our favorite movies and games that
all evokes similar feelings of awe and
intrigue that I personally had when I
saw the pulse rifle for the very first
time and while many will pay tribute or
iterate on this grenade launching
granddaddy of science fiction there is
one thing that is certain that for the
USMC sm4 one a pulse rifle it's far from
game over man game over
thank you so much for joining us on this
deep dive into an 80s sci-fi icon for
more videos just like this one be sure
to subscribe and you won't miss our next
week's episode of loadout